all right john
john uh where'd you grow up where are
you from uh i'm from
mount clemens michigan yeah that's where
i was born
outside detroit yeah about 20 miles
north of detroit
and uh tell me about your childhood you
had uh you had both your parents
no um i grew up single-parent household
i just made me my mother and my little
brother uh
my dad my dad was in the picture
you know but he wasn't um he wasn't a
part of my daily uh wasn't part of my
daily life
yeah so it was just us three and how do
you describe your childhood
uh to be honest with you i didn't have a
bad childhood uh you know i wasn't
abused
or anything like that um you know my
mother wasn't on drugs or she wasn't an
alcoholic she was just
uh she just worked hard you know
and uh she worked two jobs all the time
so you know i never really got to see
her so me and my little brother were
usually with um my grandparents or or
aunt or an uncle or a babysitter
and um i i guess i had a relatively
normal
childhood i'd you know we were poor
which i was unaware of
you know until i got later on into my
teenage years you know
but um yeah man my childhood was
actually was all right how far did you
want school
uh i graduated uh high school and i went
to college you did
yeah so uh after after your college
years what
did you do with your life uh well
immediately after college i went to go
work for a print company um
in miami florida i received my
uh my associate's degree in graphic
design from the art institute fort
lauderdale
and i went to go work for a print
company right out of college
in miami i was a lead graphic design
artist we did
like auto wraps we screen printed
t-shirts we did banners we did flyers we
did a little bit of everything
and eventually
something led you into trouble
well yeah i mean i i mean i've been in
and out of trouble
pretty much my whole life i um i was
incarcerated from
the age of about 13 until i was about
19. oh so what was going on
as a young teenager yeah i was just
angry i guess
i didn't have any role models growing up
there was no
positive male role models in my life and
you know so i tried to kind of
my personality
[Music]
and who i who i who i actually developed
into b was heavily
influenced by mtv and because you know
at this time in the early 90s mtv was it
you know there was nothing else it was
only mtb and um
so mtv was like you know i'm that's who
where my personality came from beavis
and butthead
and you know [ __ ] all the other shows
that run mtv
and uh kids in the neighborhood uh i was
heavily influenced by the kids in the
neighborhood you know people i was
hanging around which
we didn't really live in a nice
neighborhood so i mean i guess you could
imagine you know the influences that uh
which weren't that good you know so i i
started
uh i started stealing you know real
young shoplifting uh braking and
entering stealing bikes
breaking into cars stealing cars
when i was about 13 14 years old and
then it just kind of progressed
uh the crimes kind of just progressed
from there into my teenage years so
yeah i spent a lot of time in uh
juvenile halls uh boysville
um you know maxie's bts uh boot camp
uh i did about i was there about 10 or
11 months out of every year i was
incarcerated from about
13 until about nine years you were a
trouble maker i was yeah
i was a troubled youth for sure yeah
i started scanning you know real young
as a kid
uh with with photoshop i would make like
uh i would print little
like upc labels so i could go and get
like free food from like
restaurants and [ __ ] in south beach um
the scams started early you know it was
just it was just a way for me to survive
so you're blending your artistic talent
with uh
your scamming yeah yeah wherever
wherever something had a weakness or
could be
exploited i just took advantage because
i was just some uh somehow i was just
clever enough to figure
figure it out yeah so so when scamming
came along when the credit card [ __ ]
came along
after i was let go consequently from my
job um
because the owners kind of were getting
indicted by the feds
uh and i showed up for work one morning
in the fbi they were there they were
shutting everything down
and the owner's wife uh she came and
she's cut
like me and like three other people with
checks for the rest of the year for our
salary
because we were on salary and she says
uh go cash these now
we would immediately go cash them and
she's like you know it is what it is
it's a wrap
um so at this time i'm buried in student
debt
um i couldn't get another job making
what they were paying me i was they were
paying me something real ridiculous like
60 a year 65 a year
and i just couldn't nobody else wanted
to pay me that money and
i was buried in student loans so i
started looking into
alternative means of of you know ways to
finance
my life which at this point you know i
had a nice
condo in downtown miami on brickell um
i was driving a brand new car you know
what i mean i had money in the bank
because i was making really good money
and then
it just all went away and now all i have
is left is debt
and there's no income coming in and now
i've got debt so now i have to create a
new stream of of
income um and fraud was just that's
where my brain
immediately went you know and this is
early 2000s this is probably
2 000 uh about 2005 or so
you know so fraud in in in credit card
fraud
and all of that [ __ ] was like just
starting to sprout
here in the united states you know what
i mean like it was in the 90s it was you
know like
uh it was different you know because and
then then when the 2000s came
in it added the whole technology started
really kicking the internet
um devices you could make to get credit
card information
from different networks was all starting
to come into play and
i was just in the right place at the
right time you know and i just i started
i got in early when everything was just
taken off and
like i said i'm clever and i kind of
just figured it out and it just
snowballed
um as it went on so you you chose credit
cards as the
avenue to yeah yeah it just perfect
just doing just doing my research and
you know figuring out all of the ways to
make money
karting was just was it i knew that i
knew that there was something there like
i didn't have it all figured out
and i didn't really have all the pieces
of the puzzle put together but i knew in
the beginning that this is where the
money was i just had to figure it out
and and i i did a little research on
amazon you can buy all the pieces you
need to
you can and this is this is pre amazon
so
it was ebay it was actually where i
bought most of the equipment
to make credit cards to do what i did
yeah a lot of the bigger printers and
stuff i bought ebay
um i had to go to a different couple
little specialty companies to get a few
things but yeah for the most part
everything's just readily available on
the internet plastic cars the embossing
everything everything except for
the holograms the visa and mastercard uh
physical holograms but with a little bit
of
a little bit of research on the internet
those aren't hard to find but but the
information
that's connected with that that card
number
so to actually encode the card the that
information uh comes from a third party
source
um somebody who is a hacker which i'm
not a hacker i'm a counterfeiter
i you know i don't my expertise wasn't
you know breaking into computers or
coding or anything like that i'm
i'm an artist at the end of the day so
counterfeiting is just what i do
or what i did rather and
so that's that's a whole different side
of the operation that is actually for
that is actually from a hacker
you know somebody who gains access to uh
servers where this information is
is stored and then they resell it uh on
the dark web
but i didn't deal with that that side of
the of the operation all i did was make
the plastic
and you would sell the cards to people
yes i would sell the plastic
yeah so you were you weren't necessarily
making cards for yourself to go by uh
in the beginning i was yeah so i
actually started um how i got into it is
i just started buying the cards
myself and then going to walmart you
know
best buy wherever and then you know
buying large electronics and then
selling those and that's how i got into
it uh initially
yeah but there's a market for this yeah
there's a big big market on the dark web
sure yeah interesting yeah
and how long did this last
i had a good five-year run i say five
solid years
from from when i very first started all
the way up until when the secret service
um subsequently got me in 2009. what
kind of money were you making
at the very pinnacle of what i deemed to
be my success i was doing a hundred
orders a month
on average and a hundred orders with me
was it was a thousand dollars
minimum order uh for a thousand dollars
you got a hundred uh
blank visa or mastercards
and i would work with you on the
driver's licenses because i also made
those
as well so at the very pinnacle of my
success i was doing about 100 orders a
month which is roughly about a hundred
thousand dollars a month
yeah for you know and that wasn't every
month you know some months would be 20
orders some months would be
40 anywhere between 20 and 100 orders
but yeah
so i was it was good money yeah
stressful lifestyle not as much as you
would think
you're just like selling something it's
just my attitude i guess towards it you
know i just i was never paranoid i was
always comfortable
because a it was just me i
didn't involve anybody in what i was
doing nobody knew what i was doing you
know i didn't tell everybody what i was
doing um
and b my fundamental understanding of
internet security protocols just gave me
a piece of mind
you know
it's pretty hard to track you down uh if
you were just trying to find me
uh my digital footprint yes it's
impossible
i'm a ghost if i want to be
and the people you'd sell to would be
all over all over the world all over the
world
uh yeah south america brazil uh columbia
i was sending cars to russia
uh switzerland uh all over the uk
how much was in the u.s
i'd say about maybe 20 25
of my sales were us-based really yeah
and then how'd you get caught uh
well i moved to rock hill south carolina
and that was the nail in the coffin um
you know my ignorance my
comfortableness me being just a little
bit too comfortable and you know
me going to south carolina there was two
ups stores
and i had to go to i had to rotate to
send out my packages
whereas in south florida where i was
operating
you could put ups store in your gps and
you can you can hit a different one
every day
every day of the week for months and you
would never have to you know what i mean
so
so yeah they they set me up at a ups
store they figured out which ups store i
had been sending uh my cards out of
the old man at the ups store opened my
box
and went through and found what i'd been
sending out he contacted the postmaster
general
postmaster general contacted the secret
service and then they set me up
and i when i went there one day to pick
up a package they they were there away
so it was an employee at the ups store
that uh
it was the owner and i didn't know he
was the owner
yeah so he's the one who started the
investigation into you yeah yeah
sure was why would you what you're
sending have been suspicious to him
uh did you have the tattoos on your head
you know no i didn't at this time i had
a few but i didn't have
not anywhere where i look like today
this is 12 13 years i can imagine south
carolina they'd be
it was a small town i was a young kid i
was driving a brand new cadillac
i was coming in there two or three times
a week and my packages were going all
over the world
so he probably thought it was drugs yeah
he probably thought it was drugs pills
or something like that
right yeah yeah yeah and then how did
the
feds gonna get onto you uh the
postmaster general contacted the secret
service
and the secret service uh went to the
ups store asked
for you know the what they showed it to
them they seen that it was i think it
was like 500
visa cards blanks i was sending out and
then um
i had a package coming in that day so
they sent me an email telling me i had a
package which i
coincidentally i did so i went to go
pick up my package and then the secret
service was there waiting on me so so
like i've had my card hacked many times
over the years
where all of a sudden someone is using
my card for buying
groceries or gas or computers or phones
whatever in texas or in
florida or wherever that's where that's
what it is that's what it is that's what
it is that's the whole it's the whole
thing yeah
see anytime you go to say walgreens
walmart
cbs you know best buy anywhere anywhere
where you swipe that thing or put your
chip in
that information that's held on your
card that's encoded to your card is
subsequently saved to a server somewhere
it's it's held somewhere now with these
kids in eastern ukraine
russia what they do is they hack this
information which is
you know the physical which is the it's
called dump is the is the terminology
for it
uh and it's the it's the it's the
information that's encoded to the back
of your credit card now
that information is sold to people who
actually buy cards from people like me
who who make them and then
with a very very cheap inexpensive piece
of equipment they can just
code it code your [ __ ] so you're selling
the cards
someone else is encoding it yes so so so
say you're you're
the end customer okay you buy you buy a
blank piece of plastic from me
and then you have another vendor who you
buy the numbers from that were hacked
now with the numbers and the plastic and
and one other little tiny piece of
equipment you can encode
that person's debit card information to
a piece of plastic that i sold you so
you you have somebody else's
now you have it now you can go anywhere
you want and use it and they can hold up
to any scrutiny they can put it under a
black light they can swipe it
anything and they know what your limit
is on your credit card and all that no
see we'll see that's the thing
is you don't really know how much money
someone has in their bank account
you know what i mean like i don't know i
mean there's no way for me to tell that
there's no way i can check your balance
you know what i mean so it's like you
have to like pick the right bin number
and uh a bin number is a what's what's
called a bank identification number it's
the first six digits of any credit card
debit card on the planet will tell you
what bank issued it uh whether it's a
a gold card a visa card a debit card
a platinum card it'll give a designation
for what card
that is so by the bin number you can
kind of guestimate
a rough estimate of how much money is
going to be in the bank but then you
just never know
at the end of the day yeah because i
notice when my card gets hacked
the first few transactions small very
small
they want to test the card out they test
it to see if it's going to if it's going
to work
and then they go for the big purchase
and then i get a call from the credit
card company saying you know did you
purchase
yeah that those are rookie mistakes
though those are rookie mistakes because
you're just supposed to go for the big
purchase because now the little ones are
getting them getting them shut down
because now they know what to look for
so yeah i'm gonna go buy a soda real
quick to see if it'll work and then i'll
go to best buy
and then it gets shut down so you're
just supposed to go for the big one
right away
and that's why you're supposed to have
two or three backups but yeah
interesting it's it's a whole thing man
yeah so when they came for you how did
they how did that happen
uh no i just i walked in
i just walked in to get a package and i
signed for it and i kind of just felt
like everything was normal
and i went to go walk out the door
uh here were two secret service agents
walking in plain clothes and i didn't
really i seen a gun in a badge is the
first thing i've seen i'm like [ __ ]
and then they're like mr pearson um
which is the name i was using at that
time i was
using the alias ryan pearson at that
time
and um i was like yeah uh they're like
well we need to talk to you about what
you've been standing out of here
and i tried to i played stupid for a
couple of seconds
because i was kind of panicking and i
was like what do you mean and they were
like they both kind of looked at me like
we have your we we have your your
package you sent out here we know what
you've been sending out i'm like [ __ ]
they're like well let's listen listen
let's go let's go on back and talk i was
like all right so we going back to the
ups store and we're talking
and i sit down and i'm like
that you know that scene you've seen of
course you've seen that movie blow
and the the scene at the very end when
you know when he realizes that all his
homies [ __ ] him and he knows he's
[ __ ] and he's sat there he's like all
right [ __ ] it let's do it
i literally said that those words came
out of my mouth i just sat down i was
like all right [ __ ] it let's do it
they're like what's your name and i told
him i was like john bozeak and
immediately they got i had blackberries
and they hopped on their blackberry put
my name in
just so they could see if i was telling
the truth pull up my picture do my
background i gave them my name my date
of birth my social security number
like what you've been sending out of
here i was like credit cards
and they were like um you know how long
how long have you been doing this and i
was like
only a couple of months um you know uh
and i and i told you i just sell them on
the internet
i was like i do it out of my bedroom i
was like i just have a small printer
and i just i sell on the internet and i
make you know a couple hundred bucks
every month that was the story that i
told them in in the beginning in my
initial
um in my initial interrogation when they
initially busted me
and that's the story that i stuck to all
the way up until my
um my sentencing i didn't i didn't i
never [ __ ] being from that story i
stuck to all my facts
100 percent and i never [ __ ] veered
from that story even when they called me
down
i later didn't dig this they didn't
arrest me they put me in the back of
their car
took me to my house they had a bunch of
paper because listen i was like listen
i wasn't going to play ball i wasn't
going to tell him anything because i'm
at this point i'm going to jail
you know what i mean so i'm like [ __ ]
i'm going to jail i'm not going to give
these [ __ ]
anything you know what i mean so then
i'm like well
they're like well if you play ball
you're not going to go to jail
and like i'm not going to go to jail
they're like yeah i mean so they were on
the phone with their superior with their
with their uh with their captain
uh they put him on speaker phone and we
had like a little comp phone conference
back there
in the back of the ups store with the
head of the of the
of the southern district of the united
states secret service like the head dude
and like the field agents and they were
like um
because i think that they thought i was
part of i was just a small cog and a
bigger wheel
yes and initially i think that's what
they were hoping for
and i realized that immediately when
they didn't put me in cuffs
i knew two things a they don't know who
i am and they don't know
the full extent of what i've been doing
because if they did we wouldn't be
having a conversation right now and i'd
be in handcuffs
b they think i'm part of something a lot
bigger
so now like now i see wiggle room you
know my my brain
automatically starts [ __ ] figuring
[ __ ] out and i'm like okay now i
now i know i can i have a little bit of
room to negotiate with these [ __ ]
so i signed some papers saying that they
could come to my house and search and
seize and all that [ __ ]
they put me in the back of their car
they drive me to my condo they came in
they searched the whole place
they confiscated anything with removable
storage on it
so laptops hard drives you know at this
at this time there was like i had
digital we had digital cameras because
cell phone like cameras on cell phones
weren't even like really a thing back
then
uh yeah so anything with digital storage
they confiscated
uh and they didn't arrest me and i had
guns at the house i had
several assault rifles uh handguns and
everything they left all my guns there
i had we had marijuana at the house and
mind you this is south carolina
marijuana is illegal there and this is
you know
in 2009 so this was before medical and
[ __ ] was even
you know um so yeah you know they left
that there they're like well we're not
the atf
we don't care about the the guns and the
drugs we just want the [ __ ] the
computer equipment and all the frauding
equipment and all that [ __ ] so yeah
so yeah they took everything and then
they gave me their card and they said um
we need you to come down to this address
on this date and it was like two weeks
away or so it's like two weeks so you're
free
yeah they stayed two weeks they're like
you need to come down to this you need
to be at this address if not you'll have
a warrant out for your rest obviously
and uh i had to go down to the uh
headquarters um
in columbia south carolina the the
secret service headquarters i had to go
down there
uh in two weeks they gave me a date to
be there
yeah wow and that was it that was
pretty much pretty much it i showed up
two weeks later to the interview and i
walk in
and there's probably 15 or 20 people
sitting at this table and these were all
older gentlemen
you know what i mean these weren't like
the young young bucks these were all
like
seasoned guys and uh so apparently they
had flown people in from washington dc
from vegas
from california they flew people in from
all over the country like you know top
guys
and they had in the middle of the table
they had screenshots of
all of my posts from online like
all of them from every single forum i
had been on they had all my screenshots
because i had a shop
on all the forums because i was i was
like one of the the biggest vendors
on all of the forums this is now mind
you this is early 2000s so this is pre
dark web
this is pre onion router this is
pre-silk road
this is before all of that so really
there was just
carding forums and i was the [ __ ] like i
was the biggest vendor on all the forums
i was the guy
you know what i mean i was the guy that
everybody was buying from
so they had screenshots of all my
[ __ ] all my posts laid out and they
were just asking me questions
and they they just tore me apart for
like three and a half hours but i never
veered from my story
ever never veered from my story you know
so uh so did they catch on how how big
you were
no um you know what what ended up
happening was
when i went to court um i was blessed
with
the with the best public defender you
could ever ask for
uh her name was catherine everett um out
of out of columbia south carolina
she was i don't know if she is now but
she was a public defender for the uh
federal court system
and we figured out that the gentleman
who opened my package was not supposed
to
there's a chain of command you're
supposed to file he was supposed to
contact the postmaster general the
postmaster general is the only one with
the authority to open
federally sealed mail so right then and
there
they had to throw out possession of
counterfeiting equipment they had to put
they had to throw out
um uh possession of a the fraudulent
transaction devices
they had to throw out the manufacturing
of fraudulent transaction devices
they had to throw out um the mail fraud
the wire
they had to get rid of all of that the
only thing that they could charge me
with was the
aggravated identity theft because i had
my picture on someone else's driver's
license that i had made
and that carries a mandatory minimum of
24 months
and that was it wow i walked how lucky
yeah i walked that's incredibly lucky
yeah for you yeah and by time i got in
and mind you between 2009 and when i got
sentenced
it was like three years something
happened they lost the paperwork or they
just didn't
indict me or they took them three years
to federally indict me
between when i got picked up in 09 when
i got busted in 09 and when i got
picked up in 2012 or 13. so you only did
and then i did 24 months i got out in
2015.
yeah yeah but i actually started between
in those three years i actually started
back up making credit cards again
yeah i mean what are you gonna do i mean
i had a little bit of money like put
aside and like i ran through that in
like a year
after you got out after i got out and
like me and my in my
and the girl i was with my baby's mother
split up because of
you know everything that had happened so
i was like
what am i gonna do you know what i mean
i thought that i was they weren't to
prosecute me or something i'm like after
after the first year
um yeah so i took the little bit of
money i had and i bought more equipment
and i just [ __ ] started making credit
cards again i went on to make like
another million and a half dollars
in between the time when they caught me
and again when i when they picked me up
again
after that oh so so they yeah this is
before you did your serious time
this is before i went and did like the
24 months four months or whatever yeah
wow yeah interesting how many people are
doing this you think across the u.s
now it's so widespread it's like a
wildfire
it's literally like wildfire i think
probably one out of every five
teens or youth um are probably
committing some kind of fraud one way or
another yeah it's
it's like the popular culture it's it's
soaked its way into popular culture now
and now kids that aren't even doing
fraud are saying they're fraudsters and
saying they're scammers
it's gotten to that point now yeah but i
mean this was so subculture back you
know when i was
20 years ago you know when i was doing
it it was so like
you know nobody knew what was going on
interesting world we live in isn't it it
is it is yeah
so where does your life go from here how
old are you uh i'm 36
36 i just turned 36 i um you have a son
or you have your child i do yeah yeah i
have two kids i i have two boys
yeah i have two boys uh and you know i
i'm
i try to be the best i can to them you
know i'm in constant contact with my
kids
uh you know my one son he just turned 13
and me and him
on instagram every single day face
timing and we talk and you know [ __ ]
like that
um you know so yeah i'm trying to be a
good person and i'm trying to
you know be a good dad and um
i just i just focus on you know my my
artwork now and i'm a
full-time tattoo artist i tattoo so
you're not doing anything that's gonna
get you in
no no no no no nothing like that no no
i'm doing youtube now man
i got my own youtube channel and i'm
just that's just my life now
yeah i'm fully consumed by it yeah
that's great
is it what have you learned from this i
mean do you have regrets about doing it
or do you see it as
i don't have any regrets man no no i
don't have any regrets in life i know
i may have you know heard a lot of
people i may have inconvenienced a lot
of people
uh financially but at the end of the day
i don't regret
anything that i've done because i kind
of look at it
as it's
it's everything that we go through in
life it's the people we see
it's the experiences we have it's the
decisions we make it's
all of that cumulatively that make us
who we are
you know and i'm happy with who i am
like i today i am i'm
genuinely happy with who i am as a
person and i like who i am and you go
back and you change
any one component in that in that chain
and i may not be who i am today or be
where i am today and i'm
i'm happy with that you know so no i
don't have any regrets at all
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
that's a good question the most
important lesson i've learned thus far
in life
uh is just to trust your instincts and
if something doesn't feel right or
you see that your life is going in a
direction you know that
hopefully you have the the foresight to
see
things like that that you can change it
you know and i've just learned the most
important lesson is just to kind of make
good decisions and think about tomorrow
you know because the older i get the
more the more
i think about the bigger picture and the
more i start thinking years out
as before i was only thinking like day
to day and that was just my life it was
just what am i gonna do today what am i
gonna do tomorrow and
my thought process never went beyond
that you know and then when i started
making a lot of money and i started i
started seeing
my world opened up a little bit and i
started thinking months out in advance
and now i'm thinking like decades i'm
thinking decades out in advance yeah
i used to play a lot of chess when i was
young back in school and
uh that taught me how important every
single move we make
everything you do everything you do that
the little thing that you just
did is going to play a role in what
where you're at
two or three years from now i agree yeah
people don't i see so many people that i
interview that are just like going day
by day and just doing whatever they do
every day
it's like the move you make today
affects you in some it does weird
indirect way it does where you're at in
three years yeah i'm on a mission
i'm on a [ __ ] mission and i have a
plan you know what i mean and every
single day i wake up i'm
proactively trying to make my life
better and trying to put myself into a
better position to where
tomorrow i'm going to be more
comfortable or tomorrow i'm going to
have more money
or tomorrow i'm going to be closer to
the goals that i'm trying to achieve
you know and that's what my whole
mission in life is and that's what my
whole youtube
channel is about you know just setting
goals and trying to be successful in
life
you know and helping other people kind
of maybe avoid the same pitfalls
that i did and i think you know maybe in
the future i want to get into
um i want to get into working with
at-risk youth
you know because my childhood was so
[ __ ] crazy and wild
you know what i mean like just being
homeless for so many years and being on
the street and
like i feel like man i could really like
i can genuinely help
you know teenagers what do you think it
is about our society at least here in
the u.s
that makes i don't know what for lack of
a better word
being bad so attractive like like you
mentioned earlier the kids that want to
be
counterfeiters and and and drugs are
more prevalent than ever and and
you know even bad is the term bad is is
a
compliment now it's our it's pop culture
maybe i think a pop culture has a lot to
do with it
um the romanticizing of the gangsters
from the 1920s and 1930s
you know capone and that and then you
know going into the 90s and
it's the it's the anti-hero it's the
underdog it's the
you know the great american uh romance
story is you know the american gangster
it's just it's so ingrained in our
culture and our pop culture and
it's just it's the zeitgeist of our time
and i think it always will be
yeah it's very interesting yeah all
right john thank you so much for sharing
your story
cool man appreciate it thank you
you